[Music]
i had this crazy dream that we could
turn the small critical mass of the time
of researchers in deep learning and
reinforcement learning in montreal into
something big that would have an impact
on society and that would make montreal
a central hotbed of ai in the world and
we tried to convince people to help us
to build that dream and it worked and
here we are ai is becoming a tool in the
hands of scientists engineers medical
researchers i'm sure
that
the impact of ai in the next 10 years
will be amazed
just like
we have been amazed by the progress in
the last 10 years mila is one of three
canadian research institutes in ai and
our goal is to be a global pool for
scientific advances that inspires
innovation and the development of ai for
the benefit of all mila is a community
of a thousand people so to make that
work you need some shared values some of
the core values that are shared here are
around rigor excellence collaboration
innovation diversity inclusion and many
more
in a very short period of time mila has
become recognized worldwide as one of
the leading research institutes in
artificial intelligence the size of the
institute has more than tripled in a
very short period of time i would say
that mila is central to the quebec
strategy mila track talent from around
the world and enterprises that invest in
the field of artificial intelligence
because they go where the talent is and
that's what will allow us to remain in
the top tier institutes in the world
forever mila and the ai ecosystem with
the other partners
bring together fantastic researchers
business leaders
startups
we're close to government departments
that matter for the success of our
innovation initiatives
meal is a great community it's an
opportunity to work with many very
talented students and colleagues so
really it's drawing on the talents of
all these people to do better research
miele is actually a very unique place it
combines amazing energy from students
and postdocs from young researchers
with amazing group of professors from
multiple universities and this is like a
critical mass of energetic and
experienced researchers that i think
makes breakthroughs and artificial
intelligence possible mila is really the
place where if you want to collaborate
with people from very diverse cultural
backgrounds or educational backgrounds
really you can just you know help a
super interesting project and maybe
that's just the project that's going to
change your whole career trajectory i
think overall mila is really just the
perfect place it's just a nurturing
environment for you to you know discover
your interest discover what your passion
is and really just find yourself
ai is powering the translation systems
that are making society function better
and help people communicate miele is an
extraordinary world leader in ai
research and a hub between academia
industry and in many cases policy that
intersection and the focus that miele
places on societal benefit is really
unique the 21st century is also the
center of ai we can use ai techniques to
accelerate the process of drug discovery
to treat very complex diseases like
cancer or enzymes personally i'm super
excited about the potential research
advances that that i see in front of us
that could change the game
scientifically and and also in terms of
society
[Music]